it's been about two weeks since Apple's
new M2 iPad Pro has been in our hands
and honestly I'm kind of struggling to
figure out what's really new about it
seriously if you guys gave this thing to
me and told me I wasn't allowed to look
at the back of it where it now Sports
the new iPad Pro text I probably
wouldn't notice that it was the new M2
model unless I was specifically looking
for it and that's me a techie who's been
testing and reviewing iPad Pros since
before the 10.5 inch model got 120 hertz
Pro Motion in 2017. now imagine the
average person who isn't educated on all
of the differences between the previous
M1 and the new M2 they would probably
have no idea this is the new one and
that's also probably why the M2 iPad Pro
is already on sale on Amazon yes just
two weeks after launch right before the
holiday season when demand should be at
its best the new iPad Pro is already 50
off making it probably the first time
I've ever seen an iPad Pro get
discounted this quickly so to make sense
of that I'm gonna go through each of the
features that Apple showed off when they
marketed this M2 iPad Pro in their
promotional video but first I've got to
mention that it's not all bad news don't
worry there are some good things about
it that actually impressed me more than
I expected so stick around for that the
first major feature Apple showed off in
their video was the new M2 Chip with up
to 15 faster CPU performance and 35
faster GPU performance and after testing
multiple benchmarks like geekbench
speedometer 2.0 web browsing speed and
gaming tests I can safely say that the
math checks out and the M2 is actually
that much faster the only problem I have
is how Apple marketed the performance
making it seem like this is something
new with doctors now being able to work
with complex 3D models architecture CAD
Pro projects and photographers being
able to edit massive images faster than
ever the truth is that for many of the
apps people use even for photo editing
apps and others like they showed off the
M1 iPad Pro already handled those with
ease being perfectly smooth and having
no issues mainly because the apps on the
App Store are limited compared to high
performance apps you can find on Mac OS
so in the real world the M2 Chip isn't
really that big of a deal in terms of
real world performance and editing
experience the M1 was already doing a
killer job then Apple went on to show
that you can edit prores footage with
ease because of the built-in encoders
and decoders but as soon as we got our
new M2 iPad Pro in the office we
downloaded iMovie including the latest
update that just came out two days
before launch day and to our surprise
there was basically no difference
between the and one and the M2 which
means that their own app didn't support
the new encoders and decoders which is
one of the main things Apple showed off
in their video and yes I know that they
were using the new DaVinci Resolve app
but that's not launching for a while so
we use the app with the latest update
and it's a no-go now moving on Apple
also shut off the advanced cameras on
this new iPad Pro which can for the
first time record prores video making it
a complete movie studio right in your
hands but before I tell you the Shady
truth I discovered about this new
feature I've got to tell you about our
sponsor exters Black Friday bundle
that's 35 off and includes a convenient
key case for organizing Keys a cash clip
and the coolest wallet I've ever seen
the parliament wallet with this really
cool ejection mechanism for your cards
so check it out using the links below
now getting back to the new prores
recording mode when I began testing out
this new M2 iPad Pro I decided to see
how much better prores looked compared
to regular video formats but I was
stumped when I couldn't find the prores
format toggle in the camera settings I
thought maybe I needed a software update
nope it was on the latest software and I
still couldn't find it well it turns out
that Apple doesn't even allow you to
capture prores with the stock camera app
they literally force you to download
third-party software just to be able to
record prores so it turns out that the
whole prores thing is more marketing
than anything else especially if you
consider that the cameras on the new
iPad Pro have not changed one bit
compared to the previous model which had
cameras from the iPhone 12 generation
which are drastically worse than the new
iPhone 14 Pro Models so anyone in their
right mind would be shoot shooting
prores with that iPhone instead now the
next big thing that Apple showed off was
the fact that this iPad Pro now supports
Wi-Fi 6E which in itself is actually
really cool because it future proofs
this iPad but there are a couple of
important caveats the most important one
is that you need a Wi-Fi 6E router to
take advantage of the new six gigahertz
band which a lot of people don't have
including myself because they're still
very expensive but making it even worse
to take advantage of the six gigahertz
band Apple says you need a Wi-Fi 60
router that also has its 2.4 gig and 5
gig bands enabled and they strongly
encourage using a single network name
across all of the bands for the best
performance this this literally shows
that apple is not confident that the new
six gigahertz band will even give you a
better experience so they set it up in a
way that it automatically switches away
to the older bands if the connection is
spotty which kind of defeats the purpose
of Wi-Fi 6E if you're gonna be on the
old bands most of the time anyway but
nevertheless let's move on to the next
one we have the apple pencil hover
feature which is pretty neat and it'll
definitely help people see what they're
about to draw but it honestly seems like
a software feature they could have
implemented years ago if they really
wanted to but they held off until they
needed to add extra random features to
sweeten the deal but back to the rest of
the marketing video they literally just
rehashed a bunch of other software
features that are also available on
previous iPad models and that's it so
because of all of that I've got to call
this these smallest iPad Pro update of
all time even smaller than the a12z iPad
Pro in 2020 and that's why we've been
telling people to just buy the M1 iPad
Pro renewed on Amazon for as low as 605
bucks with a 90-day money-back guarantee
but wait there is some good news that I
mentioned in the beginning of this video
there is one area where I was pleasantly
surprised by the new iPad Pro and that
was in terms of gaming performance
because of the huge boost in graphics
performance compared to the previous
model the new M2 iPad Pro does quite
well for heavy Graphics related tasks
Dame Tech on YouTube tested out the new
iPad Pro with the most graphically
demanding game available on the iPad
genshin impact and it ran at 90 FPS
average a 16 Improvement compared to the
M1 which honestly isn't that much but
the impress aggressive part was the peak
temps being very low at just 36 degrees
Celsius meaning that the extra Graphics
overhead allows it to use less power
this basically means that this iPad Pro
will be set for the future when even
more demanding games and apps get
released and that's basically the one
reason you'd want to buy this new M2
iPad Pro future proofing you've got the
faster M2 Chip the Wi-Fi 6E support and
the Bluetooth 5.3 as well so it's
actually a great choice if you skipped
out on the last couple of iPad Pro
generations and you're finally ready to
upgrade especially since it's on sale
for 750 right now on Amazon and that's
just about the only positive thing I
have to say about the M2 iPad Pro so for
everybody else just wait until the next
one in 2024 because we're expecting a
new dual stacked OLED display a full
redesign with Max safe wireless charging
support the M3 chip built-on three
nanometer and probably more so with that
said if you enjoy this review click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]